[Musica]
[Applauso]
quando qualche mese fa ho iniziato a
raccontare al team di the di efficienza
circa il top che avrei voluto fare su
questo palco
ho raccontato loro sia la mia esperienza
sui social media sia dal punto di vista
professionale in quanto mi occupo
appunto digital media per il brand di
una multinazionale sia dal punto di
vista personale in quanto credo
fortemente che i social media possono
essere veicolo di forza e abbiano delle
opportunità un po inesplorate
poi sono andata a casa ho aperto il mio
pc sono tasse youtube
l'ho fatto una cosa che forse non avrei
dovuto proprio esattamente fare se ho
digitato the dix social media ne sono
comparsi questi i social media stanno
destabilizzando la tua salute mentale di
iscriviti dei social media
perché i social media stanno rovinando
la tua vita
ora ovviamente non sono proprio degli
sfizi esattamente proprio in linea col
messaggio che volevo portarvi però
vedete questo qui è un dato di fatto il
nostro stato d'animo verso i social
media è cambiato negli anni e sono
sicura che se avessi fatto questa
ricerca qualche anno fa probabilmente
sarebbe stato diverso
era il 2008 le prime delle prime
piattaforme di social media iniziavano
ad arrivare nel territorio italiano ed
eravamo tutti i curiosi
io ero all'università in realtà e mi
ricordo che con i miei amici con gli
studenti non si parlava d'altro
eravamo sicuramente curiosi ma
soprattutto emozionati di poter
ritrovare amici che non vedevamo da
tempo e soprattutto di poter rimanere
aggiornati della vita altrui
costantemente real time
qualcuno di noi iniziava a condividere i
contenuti la quotidianità tutti i giorni
da va via un cambiamento che oggi
possiamo definire epocale
poi questo stato d'animo è cambiato è
diventato un po distante diffidente
infastidito perché vedete
d'altronde sappiamo che un mondo di cui
non ci possiamo fidare acriticamente dei
contenuti
pensate che le fake news si stima essere
tra l'otto e il 10 per cento delle
informazioni online e contemporaneamente
verrà tuttavia ci passiamo un sacco di
tempo un mese all'anno ne dormiamo 4
quindi pensate un mese all'anno quanto
tempo è questo fa sì che quando parliamo
con qualcuno talvolta non abbiamo la
piena attenzione magari sta scrollando
lo schermo del telefonino lo facciamo
tutti
sono certa che chi di voi ha figli sia
molto preoccupato dei contenuti che
queste persone possono trovare online e
anche ovviamente dei commenti negativi i
giudizi della cattiveria c'è tantissimo
social dating online e infine ovviamente
la pubblicità è rilevante presenti in
queste piattaforme
continua ad aumentare quest'anno aumento
del 11 per cento
io questo stato d'animo lo capisco in
parte lo condivido però voglio parlarvi
di un altro effetto che ho sperimentato
voglio parlarvi dell'uso dei social
media voglio parlarvi di come un uso
positivo e consapevole possa veicolare
energia forza tenacia e resilienza e per
farlo tra poco vi racconterò una storia
personale la storia di un'amicizia
l'amicizia che mi lega alla persona che
ha scritto questo messaggio
ma andiamo con ordine qual è la
potenzialità dei social network possiamo
individuare due aspetti la prima è la
connessione ovvero la possibilità che ci
danno di connetterci con più o meno
tutte le persone che conosciamo
ovviamente questa possibilità di
connessione si è concretizzata
velocemente perché i social media sono
cresciuti velocemente pensate che nel
2011 instagram aveva 5 milioni di utenti
e in quell'anno è cresciuto di dieci
volte raggiunto 50 milioni di persone
facebook ugualmente nello stesso anno
crescerà del 38 per cento
oggi i tassi di crescita non sono così
evoluti così elevati però comunque sono
sempre positivi ci sono dei ricercatori
che hanno cercato di capire cosa sia
effettivamente la possibilità di
connessione 1 statuti e carichi nel 1929
che parla della teoria dei sei gradi di
separazione ci dice semplicemente
ogni persona può raggiungere qualsiasi
altra persona nel mondo con una catena
di relazioni con non più di cinque
intermediari
quindi noi potenzialmente potremmo
raggiungere qualsiasi persona appunto
nel mondo qualsiasi altra persona
semplicemente conoscendo altre cinque
persone due anni fa i ricercatori di
facebook hanno detto ok però con il
social media sarà cambiato qualcosa
infatti hanno scoperto che i gradi di
separazione due anni fa erano 3,57
quindi effettivamente sta somiglia
sempre più facendo questa la missione di
facebook bring world closer to che darà
quindi di unirci sempre più se noi 7
miliardi di persone domani fossimo tutti
sulla stessa piattaforma
probabilmente saremo distanza di un solo
click la seconda potenzialità è la
possibilità di informazione e
informazione non intesa come
accessibilità dell'informazione online
perché sappiamo che ovviamente la rete
ci fa accedere alle informazioni online
ma intesa come possibilità di accedere a
diverse tematiche di informazioni che ci
sono sui social è certo come abbiamo
detto prima ovviamente non sono tutte
qualitative c'è anche della spazzatura
però siamo sempre noi selezionatori
connessione e informazione stabiliscono
il valore del network tutti noi quando
condividiamo i contenuti lo facciamo
proprio per il valore che riceviamo
indirettamente o direttamente dai nostri
contatti
e anche qui gli studiosi hanno detto ma
cosa significa valore del network
metcalf i datori delle reti ethernet
forse lo conoscete dice l'utilità il
valore di un network è proporzionale al
quadrato dei suoi utenti
semplicissimo più utenti più valore poi
due ricercatori del minnesota hanno
detto ok però non è che tutte le persone
sono uguali non è che tutti
effettivamente diamo lo stesso valore di
questo bisogna tenere conto
giustissimo quindi dipende anche dal
valore ricevuto da ogni contatto
moltiplicato per il numero degli utenti
io vorrei aggiungere una riflessione in
quanto secondo me il valore dipende
anche dal contesto dalla situazione in
cui si trova chi veicola il messaggio
allora vi racconto un aneddoto era 2015
io ero a parigi in un quartiere centrale
era un venerdì sera stavo cenando con un
mio amico un certo punto il ristoratore
riceve l'ordine di chiudere e accompagna
tutti i commensali verso l'uscita
era la sera dell'attentato al bataclan
io non conoscevo parigi ma sapevo che
dovevo raggiungere il mio hotel card
esattamente dalla parte opposta della
città e sapevo che la città in quel
momento non era sicura non potevo
chiamare o mandare un messaggio sentire
qualcuno a casa perché le reti erano
affollate però facebook funzionava e
quindi ho fatto due cose la prima è
stato dire ai miei cari non vi
preoccupate sto bene è tutto ok
la seconda è stato cercare di capire se
c'era qualcuno del mio network che
magari conosceva qualcun altro che ci
potesse ospitare o magari ci potesse
dare delle indicazioni
ora pensate per me
che valore in quel momento hanno avuto
quei 10 commenti
non tanto per una questione logistica
ma quanto per la sensazione per il fatto
che mi sono sentita supportata mi sono
sentita che c'era un network di persone
che si stava preoccupando per me ma come
fanno le persone in un momento di
difficoltà o di poca energia ad ottenere
una grande visibilità
le dinamiche di visibilità dei social
network sono regolate da degli algoritmi
e questo ego ritmici baci mostro il
contenuto sulla base del possibile
interesse che credo non possiamo avere
per quel contenuto come fanno a saperlo
lo testano protestano su un gruppo di
utenti sul numero campioni di utenti
se quel campione di utenti ha una
percentuale di reazioni positive elevate
allora l'algoritmo dice ok questo
contenuto è rilevante lo mostriamo lo
amplifichiamo ad altre persone
ovviamente per conoscere queste
dinamiche per conoscere questi
ragionamenti bisogna conoscere le
piattaforme e le regole sottostanti e
ovviamente non solo conosciuto da tutti
di conseguenza online ci possono essere
molte persone che beneficerebbero del
valore del network ma contemporaneamente
non riescono a ottenere visibilità
e quando io ci penso credo che
sicuramente la sensazione che si può
provare una sensazione di sconforto una
sensazione non esattamente positiva e
questo mi rimanda con la mente a quando
avevo 13 anni
mio padre era ammalato dimenava multipla
una malattia che sappiamo essere
incurabile e di questi anni di battaglia
mi ricordo la sensazione una sensazione
sicuramente di distanza dal resto del
mondo
una sensazione di difficoltà di
raccontare quello che stavo provando ma
contemporaneamente di difficoltà di far
finta di nulla
avrei voluto più di ogni altra cosa un
network di supporto un network di
supporto che non sopportasse solo me ma
supportasse mia mamma mio fratello
soprattutto il mio papà ricordasse
neopapà quanto era stato forte quante
volte aveva già vinto nella sua vita
vedete io credo che questi natori di
supporto a delle persone in un momento
di difficoltà possono veramente fare
tanto
contemporaneamente so che non è facile
parlare alle persone che magari non
stanno esattamente viene in un momento
della propria vita però al digitale ci
aiuta perché ha distrutto sia le
barriere spaziali e temporali ma anche
un po le barriere emotive quindi presa
da questa mia onda emotiva l'autunno
scorso novembre
cercava on line proprio questo cercavo
dei contenuti di persone che magari
cercavano supporto ma non lo trovavano e
quindi cercavo contenuti legate alla
jacques cancel fighter e così sono
atterrata sul profilo di andrea bizzotto
un ragazzo di bassano del grappa proprio
come me di 33 anni papà di una bambina
di due anni e mezzo che misura in
germania e che aveva un sarcoma e che
diceva in questo post utilizzo instagram
per condividere la mia storia
spero di raggiungere persone nella mia
situazione che posso aiutare o che mi
possono aiutare io leggevo i suoi post
che in quel momento non riuscivano ad
ottenere una grande visibilità più in me
esplodeva la volontà di attuare questo
network di energia questo network di
supporto e quindi gli scrissi l'ho
ringraziato
per quello che stava facendo e iniziamo
a parlare iniziare a dirgli che avevo la
volontà di diffondere il suo messaggio
mi raccontò delle sue giornate mi
raccontò del grandissimo amore per sua
moglie maria mi raccontò soprattutto
della sua preoccupazione di non poter
veder crescere la sua bambina di non
poterle raccontare gli insegnamenti di
vita che aveva in serbo di non poter
condividere tutto quello che aveva con
lei e io iniziai contemporaneamente a
condividere la sua storia nei miei
canali ai miei follower chiesi alle
persone che mi seguivano di inviarli
quanta più energia possibile cercare di
spiegare loro che in casi come questo
secondo me possiamo davvero fare la
differenza
potevamo tutti insieme creare un network
di supporto che concretamente poteva
fare qualcosa e centinaia e centinaia di
persone iniziarono a seguirlo a
supportarlo a inviarli questa energia
andrea nel frattempo non stava
particolarmente bene perché ovviamente
le operazioni del polmone ai polmoni
legato questo starcom erano molto
invasivo e molto dolorose però tutte le
sere prima di andare a letto apriva il
pc e scriveva voleva scrivere un libro
per sua figlia
un libro che contemporaneamente va
rivisto da un'altra ragazza che lo stava
supportandoli treviso rebecca questo in
me
a me mostrava la sua forza di volontà e
questo network di energia questo network
di supporto queste persone che gli
inviavano in questi messaggi
contemporaneamente lo supportavano in
questa impresa lo facevano sentire meno
solo lo facevano sentire con un po di
più forza il 17 dicembre dell'anno
scorso
storia di un maldestro in bicicletta al
suo libro scritto in pochissimi mesi è
stato pubblicato e andrea
incredibilmente volava dalla germania a
venezia per presenziare a delle
conferenze di presentazione del suo
libro ricordo che era atterrato venezia
un certo punto mi disse mi scrisse sai
qualche settimana fa non riuscivo
nemmeno alzare il braccio e oggi sono
qui tra venezia e cortina che presento
il mio libro il 28 dicembre quindi in
qualche giorno dopo io mi recai a la
conferenza stampa di bassano del grappa
della città di entrambi volevo un po
dopo tanti messaggi volevo conosce
perché volevo rompere questo schermo
virtuale che c'era tra di noi un certo
punto non sapeva che io ero lì non gli
avevo ancora detto era in platea e lui
rispose una domanda e disse ricevo molti
messaggi che mi danno molta forza che mi
aiutano a combattere
penso che l'energia positiva mi abbia
dato una forza che nemmeno i medici si
aspettavano di capi che l'energia aveva
fatto il suo corso che la condivisione
aveva raggiunto il suo obiettivo è che
il valore di quel network e io tanto v
pensato in quel momento era infinito
perché stavo facendo qualcosa di
concreto che era lì davanti ai miei
occhi
einstein ha detto tra i no to become e
meno fax batte radar e man o valio io
credo che oggi nei social network per
tutti sia per tutti noi si è molto più
semplice condividere i successi
condividere le parti più patinate della
nostra quotidianità
però contemporaneamente credo che per
essere meno vario quello che dobbiamo
fare è dare una piccola parte della
nostra energia a dare una piccola parte
del nostro valore perché questo può
davvero fare qualcosa di incredibile e a
noi non costa nulla
andrea
è mancato
il primo marzo di quest'anno
con più di 10.000 copie del suo libro
vendute e nelle ultime settimane di vita
grazie alla forza di volontà che aveva è
supportato da questo momento ordine
energia pur essendo ormai senza fiato
riuscito a registrare questa canzone
from my star per sua figlia giulia grace
[Musica]
grazie
[Applauso]